Two weeks ago. You and I voted. Wait, you didn't feel my cursor right there.
Next two years. Well, the winter is better than
[inaudible] could keep them separated.
This was tricky.
65% of click voters want two separate channels. Well,
80% of commoners want just one. That's common.
Ters ters not commoners.
After re scrutinizing those youtube notes in chatting with poop comes about your
collective happiness, my personal creative pursuits.
We'll have to move off to new channel opening November 7th look for a video
invitation then, but enough distractions next Friday.
We're back to language with that.
Excuse me, something in my throat there.
So subscribe if you haven't and send it any good fan art that might fit this
picture frame here.